they have come to the high court from
across the uk in the middle here
christine from bristol who has to wear a
prosthetic arm
nikki from the isle of wight who was
born with multiple deformities and their
campaign leader mary lyon from wigan
whose daughter was born with a shortened
limb
many here are mothers with their
children who believe a drug called
primidos prescribed by doctors in the
1970s as a pregnancy test
caused the malformations when their
babies were in the womb
i obviously have problems at birth with
my limbs but with my spine that's
deteriorated over the years it's just
the frustration and the
pain and angst of seeing emma getting
worse struggling
in pain not able to work full-time
having to pay for all her medications
and there's nothing i can do about it
and we still haven't had any justice or
fairness
they are taking on two giants the
manufacturers the main one being german
firm baer who now own the company that
supplied primidos they deny there's
evidence it caused malformations
they're also suing the british
government for failing to regulate the
drug
two years ago a review team found the
drug should have been taken off the
market much sooner and the then health
secretary appeared to apologize
i want to issue a full apology to the
to the those who've suffered
and their families
for the for the frustration
but that frustration continues an
independent review team asked the
government to set up a fund to help the
victims but instead they've hired
lawyers who alongside the manufacturers
are trying to get this legal challenge
struck out
it's reprehensible
i feel quite disgusted they don't want
to hear our evidence and that really is
why they've asked for a strikeout
i think it
helped me out of order
[Music]
they refuse to act on their apology and
so you know without redress i do feel
like it's it's more of an insult to us
than anything else the drug was heavily
prescribed in the northwest and
manchester mayor andy burnham backs the
campaign
it's barely believable
that um the government are i would say
bullying the victims
of a terrible
medical negligence case in the courts i
mean how can that possibly be right the
government and the pharmaceutical
industry using their combined might to
try and silence victims it's just
utterly wrong and it renders the apology
that was given by the former health
secretary in 2020 utterly meaningless
the campaigners need to bolster their
legal representation and have resorted
to crowdfunding to cover their costs
with the support of acta and thalidomide
campaigner ricky tomlinson they've sort
of been overlooked overshadowed
and we need to bring this to attention
because they're still fighting their
case
the manufacturer bayer says that a
previous attempt at litigation against
them failed in 1982 and no new evidence
has emerged in a statement the
department of health said the government
apologized unreservedly for the time
taken to listen and respond to patients
concerns when we published our response
to the cumbridge review in july 2021
where we accepted the majority of
recommendations and 50 actions for
improvement the scientific evidence
available does not support a causal
association between hormone pregnancy
tests and birth defects
but the families disagree and after 40
years they're back in court and had a
partial success
given extra time until october to
challenge the strikeout application and
keep their new legal challenge alive
jason farrell sky news